que es una rn no codificante un aire no
codificante un arnés como se abrevia es
una molécula de arn funcional que omite
este último paso y no se traduce en una
proteína en otras palabras simplemente
pasa directamente de la transcripción a
una molécula de arn y luego realiza
cualquier cantidad de funciones vitales
dentro de la célula hay muchos ejemplos
de adn no codificante es que incluyen
micro a rn ahorre en el ribosoma y ccoo
a rm de transferencia la lista sigue y
sigue
a medida que revisamos cada uno de estos
diferentes tipos y ejemplos de adn no
codificante comenzaremos a ver que hay
una especie de tema emergente aquí es
decir la mayoría de estos genes
codificantes participan en la
transcripción o traducción de una forma
u otra comencemos con micro arn los
microarn a mí a rn funcionan en la
regulación transcripcional y post
transcripción al de la expresión génica
y lo hacen por emparejamiento con bases
de secuencias complementarias dentro d
nm o moléculas de arn mensajero esto
generalmente da como resultado el
silenciamiento génico a través de la
represión traducción al o la degradación
de la diana en esencia se impide que el
aire nm al que se unen estos micro arn
se traduzca o se encamina a su
degradación el siguiente conjunto de rn
no codificantes de los que hablaremos
están involucrados en la traducción el
primero de ellos es el derribo sónico
los ribosomas son la maquinaria celular
utilizada para traducir nm en proteínas
y están formados por un tipo de molécula
de adn el arn arribos o mico los arn de
transferencia son una molécula
adaptadora que une los cordones en una
cadena de arne m con los aminoácidos
correspondientes por lo que este es otro
tipo de arne no codificante que verán en
la traducción el tercer tipo se llama
hay rehenes no que significa a rn
pequeño núcleo largo es una clase de
pequeñas moléculas de arn que guían las
modificaciones covalentes del aire en
derribos o mikko a rn de transferencia y
rn nucleares pequeños principalmente a
través de la metilación que es la
edición de grupos metilo o la pseudo ur
y dilación que es la adición de un
isómero del núcleo sido uridina
y otra clase de aire no codificantes son
los arn pequeño nuclear arn s m que no
deben confundirse con los arneses no los
haré en el pequeño núcleo largo de los
que acabamos de hablar los pequeños
nucleares reciben su nombre del hecho de
que la longitud promedio de estas
moléculas de arn es de aproximadamente
150 nucleótidos su función principal es
el procesamiento de pre nm en el núcleo
también ayudan a regular los factores de
transcripción o una arn polimerasa
particular arn polimerasa 2 así como a
mantener los telómeros que son las
regiones de secuencias repetitivas de
nucleótidos al final de una cromática
que protege en el extremo del cromosoma
del deterioro durante la replicación
cromosómica el arn sn puede asociarse
con un conjunto de proteínas específicas
y formar complejos que se denominan
pequeñas
ribó núcleo proteínas nucleares
rnp o a veces llamados norte hay un
complejo especial de sn rnp llamado
explicó soma compuesto por cinco
pequeños
nucleares y 150 proteínas y que es
responsable de eliminar los intrones
contenidos en el arn mensajero que es un
paso importante en la modificación post
transcripción al que tiene lugar en el
núcleo de eucariotas la forma en que él
es precioso más esto es que se une a
secuencias específicas en la cadena de
arn mensajero y realiza dos reacciones
de transesterificación secuenciales que
empalman el link throne y luego ligan
los dos secciones para formar un rn m
maduro ahora conocemos un poco más
algunos ejemplos de rn no codificantes y
algunas de las funciones que realizan
dentro de la célula